you know somethin Andy I was it was kind
of an interesting experience over the
weekend I went to my first Passover
Seder I hadn't been to one of those
before and I went to one this weekend
yeah I've been to a seder I like the
part where they hide the piece of matzah
called the afikomen mm-hmm and the kid
that finds it gets a bag of prize yeah I
like that too that was crying
great yeah it's great and and I like
that i like the whole Passover
experience as well and anyway go in
there got me thinking ladies and
gentlemen let's face it there are a lot
of Christmas and Easter television
specials out there but you hardly ever
see anything about Passover and anyway
we here at the show decided to do
something about it we're presenting now
that's right our very first Passover
special now ya know we thought we should
do this there aren't enough out there
right now folks it's a it's a claymation
special because I'm I love claymation
those raisins and everything yellow yeah
it's a claymation special and it
features me Andy and a couple of
surprise guests and we're really proud
of it
take a look enjoy
[Music]
borrow ATO Adonai elohenu melech ha-olam
boray pre-hook open thank you Andy for
that beautiful prayer and to my good
friends who join me tonight for this
Passover Seder
I want to thank you individually
starting with Johnnie Cochran my name
may not be cold but I would like you to
pass me another shake bone and Tom
Schneider and last but not least Paul
Prudhomme who prepared tonight's
wonderful Seder meal food is emotion and
now we've come to the traditional part
of the evening where we search for the
piece of matzah called the afikomen it's
been hidden somewhere in this room and
the first person to find it will receive
as a reward so gentlemen if you please
on your marks get set go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Passover isn't about prizes are having
fun it's about the sufferings of the
Jewish ancestors but of course tonight
Angele men of these great lessons for
yourselves as I inflict upon you the
dreaded plagues of Egypt starting with
interests
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
Hey look I got a bag of prizes
you know tonight I think we all learned
a little more about what Passover is
really about
[Applause]
Verlaine gentlemen that is our Passover
special we hope you enjoyed it